women wanted to be in a man's world so I
say be in it be in it and fight for your
pay and if you're not going to do that
please do not cry and moan about
being on TV you are a commentator being
a commentator is one of the best jobs on
the planet I love being a commentator it
is much easier than say a plumber a
trucker or a factory worker and so many
times women are entitled to more and
more pay even though they have an
significant advantage in the space it is
much e easier to blow up as a
commentator as a woman than as a man the
men typically have to work their whole
lives to get to a point where the women
are typically given that upfront I don't
make the rules I just tell you what they
are